- [Narrator] You might be familiar with
the idea of evolution, that
species change over time.
And you can see that if you
look at old bones, old fossils,
how they change through the fossil record.
But the obvious question is,
how do these species actually do that?
What is the mechanism?
Well, one of the major
mechanisms is natural selection.
So natural selection is all based on
at any given point in time,
there is variation in a species.
There are different traits that are
expressed in different ways.
And many times, a lot of
those variations are fine,
but then you can have
environmental factors
which make some of those traits
more favorable than others.
And if those traits are more favorable
to be able to survive,
to be able to get food,
or to be able to reproduce,
well then the genes that
code for those traits
are more likely to be passed
on generation after generation.
And to make this very tangible,
I will give you the example
of the peppered moth,
which is probably the most common example
when people show evidence
of natural selection.
If you were to go to
the mid 1800s in London,
most of the peppered moths
were the white peppered moths.
There were very few black peppered moths,
but there was variation.
There would be some lighter ones,
there would be some darker
ones, and in-between.
Now what's interesting is between
the mid 1800s and the late 1800s,
you have the industrial
revolution in London
really hitting full gear.
And so there was a lot
of pollution in the air.
And so a lot of the surfaces
that the moths might rest on
like trees, or the wall of a building,
became darker and darker.
So as where these moths could
rest became darker and darker,
what do you think might have happened?
Well, some of you might guess.
In this different environment now,
as the environment has gradually changed,
all of a sudden having the
traits that make you darker
will be more favorable than they were
even 30 or 40 or 50 years ago.
And the white trait,
which might've been okay
in the mid 1800s, now all of a sudden
makes these moths very obvious to see.
So if there was a bird
that was looking for lunch,
it'd be very easy to
pick off the white moths
versus the black moths.
And what we saw is actually by the 1900s,
most of the peppered moths in London
were now darker in color.
And so what you had happening
generation after generation
is variation in the moth color.
But as the background
environment became darker,
the ones that were white colored
were easier to pick off by predators.
And if they're picked off by a predator,
they're definitely not reproducing
and passing on their genes.
And then the ones that
were able to survive
and pass on their genes
were the darker moths.
Now it's been interesting
over the last 50 or so years
as environmental regulations
have gone into effect,
and the air has started to
clean up in places like London,
you're seeing a return of
the white peppered moth.
Because once again, the surfaces
are no longer covered with soot,
and so the variants that
are lighter in color
now have a decent chance
of not being spotted.
And if anything, now the darker ones
might have a better
chance of being spotted
in this cleaner environment.